[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream 102nd one of them
2002nd what the hell am I talking about
it's the 2002nd that felt wrong I was so
confident yeah you were back mid
pandemic oh god um yes well anyway it is
the
202nd live stream of the Darkhorse
podcast I'm of course Dr Brett Weinstein
you are Dr Heather hying and uh we have
a wow I should have wored looked up the
word panoply before this but I'm just
going to use it we have a panoply of
things to discuss with you today and
it's not a panoply then I will deliver a
correction next time yeah a a a panoply
including let's see advocacy and
genocide fizer and diversity ex
exclusion I was going to say oh no
diversity equity and inclusion uh Elon
Musk and Disney more penguin Shenanigans
and maybe keyer oh yeah absolutely all
right yeah cool lots lots of good stuff
um we would normally tell you to join
our watch party on locals but apparently
that's not working at the moment so
apologies I'll work it for me if other
people find it to work yeah you may well
find it to work who knows why check
check the link and uh we will talk to
the folks at locals if it's not working
yeah um but in General on our locals uh
which we encourage you to join you get
early release of guest episodes of
Darkhorse private monthly Q&A um amas
which we haven't done recently but uh we
will resume again soon access to our
Discord server and of course hor you
have the store uh Darkhorse store.org we
are going to follow this live stream
this week with a special gift episode
and we're going to come back and talk
about um some of the stuff in the story
before you scroll though we have a new
one here uh cut that out that's all
just cut that out cut that out
yep um with the you know just the
perfect font for that I think so and I
would say that was a that was a request
uh from a a viewer after one of us I
don't remember one of us said that a
quote we were constantly thinking it for
years for years finally it just came
pouring out yeah um yes I would say the
guest the guest episode what the hell so
I've just been traveling and my brain is
uh you scrambled language on the East
Coast uh yes well I discovered something
uh on the East Coast which is that uh
for us West Coast folks it's later than
we think by about 3 hours so that's one
way of thinking about it that is one way
of thinking about it in any case that is
how I now think of it but um you want
for long that's probably right out go
back into my West Coast complacency
thinking that we still have plenty of
time um but in any case the gift episode
um I would just say if people are not
looking for a gift episode they still
might want to tune in there's a certain
amount of um philosophical thinking
about such things that will be included
there and so
anyway um might not be what you're
expecting
yeah uh so uh yes we just talked about
that we're going to move the rest of our
various announcements and such to the
end except for our carefully chosen ads
with as usual three sponsors at the top
of the hour here this week we have mind
Bloom Vivo Barefoot and uncruise so
without further Ado our first sponsor
this week is mind Bloom which offers a
new tool to improve your mental health
at home ketamine therapy there's no
quick fix for anxiety and depression
traditional anti-depressants don't work
for everyone and their side effects are
often devastating for some people
finding a new therapist will help or
starting an exercise routine or eating a
better diet but some people still find
themselves even after they do those
things stuck in the darkness sometimes
you need something to unlock your brain
a new way of thinking about and seeing
the world maybe the thing that will help
is guided ketamine therapy from mind
Bloom mind Bloom is the leader in atome
ketamine therapy having safely helped
thousands of people overcome their
anxiety and depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
anti-depressants in a study of over
12200 mind Bloom clients 89% reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only 4 four sessions
Right Now mindbloom is offering our
listeners $100 off your first six
session program when you sign up at mind
bloom.com Darkhorse and use promo code
Darkhorse take the first step and break
free from your anxiety and depression
with mind bloom once again that's mind
Bloom m i n DBL o.com Darkhorse and use
promo code Darkhorse at
checkout no single word for me I the
problem is I have used all of the words
all the adjectives I think superlatives
are in but the fact is there's a limited
Supply and so I'm need to switch
languages switching languages would be
an excellent excellent change for me at
this point unfortunately I am unskilled
in the process of switching language
it's something I'm actually looking to
change up I'll just add a word f
banan that's M agazi that means
Administrative Building that is an
inside joke if ever I've heard what I
mean it's not that inside there are I
don't know how many million people in
Madagascar Who would know exactly what
you're talking about right but um as far
as the Dark Horse audience probably only
yeah you know me I would I would think
so yes yes uh when doing work in
Madagascar one has to learn a few words
it was hard language for me to even
consider getting into and so and
actually French is um widespread my
French is terrible but it's a lot better
than my Mal agazi and so I learned to
say that there are and there are not the
things that I was most often in need of
doing independent research in Madagascar
which turned out to be mostly um frogs
administrative buildings and beer yeah
and the stuff that goes on in the Fon
banan is serious stuff ban not a hoop
you can skip you got to because the
stamp that adjusts what you are and are
not allowed to do is housed in the ficon
ban and uh anyway so yes you have to you
have to be mindful of all of the the
workings of the interstices of the
governmental structures that result in
the stamp either being deployed or not
being deployed on your behalf or being
Pres present but in a room behind a
locked door for which the key is no
longer present it might as well not it's
like a it's a philosophical puzzle is
does does it if the stamp is not wielded
does it even effectively exist no yes
that's about right that was the
conclusion we often came to philosophy
puzzle okay our second sponsor this week
is Vivo Barefoot they are one of our
very first sponsors and are one of our
favorites Vivo Barefoot makes shoes that
are made for feet everyone should try
these shoes most shoes are made for
someone's idea of what feet should be
Vios however are made by people who
actually know feet and word is spreading
people have approached us because of the
vios we wear sometimes they've heard
they're saying that they've heard
they're good and they are these shoes
are every bit as good as you've heard
they are including from us these shoes
are Beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you're
walking on is amazing and they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they're fantastic our feet
are the products of millions of years of
evolution humans evolve to walk move and
run Barefoot modern shoes that are
overly cushioned and strangely shaped
have negatively impacted foot function
and are contributing to a Health crisis
people move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
enter Vivo Barefoot Vivo barefoot shoes
are designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by 60% in a matter of
months just by walking around in them
Vil Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear there're also a
certified BP that is pioneering
generative business principles and their
Footwear is produced using sustainably
sourced natural and recycled materials
with the aim to protect the natural
world so you can run wild in it go to
viob barefoot.com Darkhorse and new
customers get 20% off all orders through
December 31st additionally all new
customers get a 100 day free trial so
you can see if you love them as much as
we do that's VI vob b f t.com dark
course for 20% off your first order find
the differences in the way you and I
present Evo Barefoot probably are not
noticed by other people but uh they are
very significant you and I have slightly
different takes on elements of Vivo
Barefoot and uh anyway close Watchers
will notice them I don't know what
you're talking about I'm curious um
let's see uh Vivo Barefoot are made by
people with feet who know how to use
them a zezy top reference which I think
is really essential to the brand I don't
know that they think so but I think so
and um so that you may run wild upon it
right you and I have oh that that that I
do notice yes the in Wild in it run wild
on it exact you say on it I say in it I
see us as part of the world but I think
it's it's it's actually stomping around
on it it is significant that this brand
of shoes is so flexible that it can
accommodate these radically different
worldviews even us who could have almost
no lesson common than we do did I say
that the correctly I don't think so yeah
oh you did yeah
okay I'm I'm on board then if you said
it right I don't know okay um our final
sponsor this week is uncued small ship
Adventures UNC Cruise explores by sea
and by land they have boats that hold
far fewer people than most cruise boats
and very high quality people I would say
based on our experience in fact we ran
into a uh a lovely young couple of
Darkhorse fans I hate that term but
people Watchers of Darkhorse and uh had
a lovely time talking to them about on
our unru adventure back in Alaska end of
April beginning of May whenever that was
you tell me when it was cuz I'm not good
at that sort of thing but um but
anyway all right where was I
uh hold for a fewer people then most
cruise boats and they take their
passengers to some of the world's most
magnificent places Panama and Costa Rica
galpagos the Sea of Cortez and Mexico
Alaska even our own backyard the San
Juan Islands we didn't expect to be
extoling the virtues of an adventure
travel company because our standards are
very high and most companies don't come
close to living up to their own hype
uncruise is the exception our years of
experience doing research in and leading
trips to remote nature areas no it says
natural areas probably no difference
including the scab lands of Eastern
Washington and the Columbia River Gorge
as well as the andian Paro Galapagos and
the Amazon has led us to the sad
conclusion that most trips do not meet
expectations in Market contrast uncruise
exceeds expectations the small boats of
uncruise allow passengers to get real
deep experience their largest boat can
accommodate a mere 86 guests the boats
of uncruise take small groups of people
to places larger boats can't go and the
excursions are designed to bring people
into deep nature without destroying it
when we spoke with CEO Dan Blanchard we
discovered a shared ethos the value of
wild roadless nature of exploration and
observation our own uncu trip through
the Inland Waters of Southeast Alaska in
early may see it says it right here was
fantastic we saw sea otters and their
pups mountain goats eagles and their
nest brown and black bears puffins orcas
humpbacks Arctic turns and more every
day we got off the boat to hike or kayak
the crew and naturalist guides were to a
person kind knowledgeable and
enthusiastic the food was remark good as
well and food preferences and
sensitivities were handled perfectly
every sailing with uncruise is all
inclusive Transportation drinks Farm
totable Cuisine daily excursions
everything is included unru understands
that the boat is just a tool their small
ship cruises take guests through the
communities and locals on the ground so
they can have actual experiences un
Cruise offers a kind of Unique Travel
experience we know our audience will
love and right now uncruise is giving
our listeners a great deal save 5 00
bucks per person if you book now you can
combine our special offer with other
savings including deals on trips to Baja
Mexico there's a comma between Baja and
Mexico I'm going to struggle over its
meaning and Alaska in
20124 start planning your next trip with
uncruise today and take advantage of our
great offer go now to
uncw.edu now to
uncruise Pages Darkhorse again that's
uncruise un NCR
ui.com
Pages
Darkhorse cool shall we
uh take a unscheduled moment to discuss
uh geography and grammar yes yeah
actually what the hell is that was that
a stray comma or have I misunderstood
something well um so Baja in that
sentence is capitalized yes indicating
uh one of I I can't remember and Zach
might be might look it up I think
there's two states in Mexico to two
Estados in Mexico that are actually part
of Baja California um I think there's
Baja s and Baja and so it's not so Baja
also means under in Spanish so if it
weren't capitalized it might be like
Southeast Alaska Baja Mexico right
southern Mexico California would be
there exactly so I in this case even
though Baja also has like a directional
me and being capitalized tells you it's
a place name yeah um all right so a
comma not an Oxford one that explains
why we give a you know yes exactly
to exactly to quote a rather poignant
song on the grammar in question yes well
it's also just like you would put a
comma before your ZIP code after the
rest of your address or something like
that there are like three different
commas you can throw in in an address I
think it's like that we're about to get
no but but the the point was Zach that I
think your dad was reading it as a a
geographical a direct a cardinal like a
cardinal direction is yeah uh and uh and
instead it's place now yep yeah you're
right uh all right I'll be reeling from
this for seconds at least seconds from
now over it good almost yeah um okay
um I thought we'd start with uh the
video you showed me this morning uh from
the University presidents uh being
grilled by uh congresswoman stefanic a
republican from New York yeah should we
start there should we show that and then
we'll discuss its meaning Dr corn Blu
yes does m at MIT does calling for the
genocide of Jews violate mit's code of
conduct or rules regarding bullying and
harassment yes or no if targeted
individuals not making public
statements yes or no calling for the
genocide of Jews does not constitute
bullying and harassment I have not heard
calling for the genocide for Jews on our
campus but you've heard transfer into
P have heard chance which can be
anti-semitic depending on the context
when calling for the elimination of the
Jewish people so those would not be
according to the mit's code of conduct
or
rules that would be um investigated of
as harassment if pervasive and severe
Miss Migel at pen does calling for the
genocide Jews violate Pen's rules or
code of conduct yes or
no if the speech turns into conduct it
can be harassment yes I am asking
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews does that constitute bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
or pervasive it is harassment so the
answer is yes it is a context dependent
decision congresswoman it's a context
dependent decision that's your testimony
today calling for the genocide of Jews
is depending upon the context that is
not bullying or harassment this is the
easiest question to answer yes Miss
McGill so is your testimony that you
will not answer yes if it uh is if the
speech becomes if the speech becomes
conduct it can be harassment yes conduct
meaning committing the act of
genocide the spe is not harassment this
is unacceptable Miss Migel I'm going to
give you one more opportunity for the
world to see your answer does calling
for the genocide of Jews violate Penn's
code of conduct when it comes to
bullying and harassment yes or
no it can be harassment the answer is
yes and Dr Gay at Harvard does calling
for the genocide of Jews violate
Harvard's rules of belief and harassment
yes or no it can be depending on the
context what's the context targeted as
an individual targeted as at an
individual it's targeted at Jewish
students Jewish individuals do you
understand your testimony is
dehumanizing them do you understand that
dehumanization is part of
anti-Semitism I will ask you one more
time does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate ard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or
no anti-semitic rhetoric when it IT
anti-semitic rhetoric anti-semitic
rhetoric when it crosses into conduct
that amounts to bullying harassment
intimidation that is actionable conduct
and we do take action so the answer is
yes that calling for the genocide of
Jews violates Harvard code of conduct
[Music]
correct again it depends on the context
it does not depend on the context the
answer is yes and this is why you should
resign these are unacceptable answers
across the
board all right okay so I don't know how
many of uh what percentage of our
audience will have seen that clip before
but it circulated like wildfire on
social media and I must say it put me in
a bind that I did not like because while
I believe that the implication of the
answers that these college presidents
were giving is what it appears to be I
thought the way the whole thing went
down actually failed to seal the deal
that is do you remember that you and I
used to be College professors I do that
rings a bell with you okay so I didn't
imagine it then um as a former college
professor a current professor in Exile
there is a degree to which one does not
want the obvious implication of this
clip to turn into
policy
because the question of what a proper
College code of conduct ought to look
like is not a simple one what does it
mean for example to advocate for the
genocide of Jews and do you want to
build a college in which people can not
make absurd arguments in the in some
context um you really don't because I
mean among other problems you'd wipe out
whole
disciplines sorry well there is that
actually those are disciplines we can do
without but but anyway the point is this
I believe that these institutions
because of their I don't even want to
call it a far-left bent cuz you and I
are are on the left and this has nothing
to do with the actual um honorable
values of the left this confused bent
the far confused bent so these
institutions have become absurd they've
become connected with a brand of
self-defined liberalism that is
Thoroughly illiberal and it has a very
aggressive strain of anti-Semitism
riddled throughout you and I experienced
this when we were College professors we
have seen it in other contexts it's just
simply there and so I believe the
answers that these presidents delivered
Academia has an anti-Semitism problem
and that's not new right it's not new
it's it's long-standing um so the
answers here are disturbing but what I
didn't hear was the questions that would
tell you whether or not the there was a
commitment to free speech on these
campuses which there clearly isn't right
um that would explain the protection of
abhorent viewpoints in a general way in
other words what I really wanted to hear
was you know your policy that appears to
allow ow for the advocacy of genocide
against the Jews does it also allow for
the same advocacy against blacks does it
allow for that advocacy against uh
transgender people in other words is it
a blind policy in which the college
recognizes that it has to tolerate
terrible things in order for for
exercises to take place that you know
the same discovery that the founders of
the country made in writing our
constitution that you are better off
leaving people free to say terrible
things than you are trying to tell them
what they're not allowed to say
precisely and so the outrage that we
hear from uh representative stefanic uh
and that we're seeing um in response
online uh is
both a real emotional response um but it
should be responding to in part the
double standard that is revealed by and
you know it's it's not in here as you
say but like we actually know from the
last several years what the response
would be to mass protests advocating for
genocide of black people right or mass
protest advocating for genocide of trans
people we we know what the response
would be the hammer would come down
swiftly and and
and and and I mean it just would and it
will even it will even come down uh in
cases where there's nothing to be
complaining about right it will it will
come down for example uh you know having
nothing to do with genocide but the
simple and I'm going to violate my own
rule here just because I don't want a
focus on you know where it would
obviously fall I'm going to use the term
Nord rather than using the actual term
in a perfectly legitimate way which is
to say discussing the academic status of
that term can we you know can we read
Huck fin yeah in the original and you
know not Allied the actual use of that
word right right um so you're going to
do it here in order to I'm going to do
it here so that we do not focus on the
fact that oh no I uttered for you know
forbidden syllables yeah um but but the
the fact
is we have we have a problem which is
that this this hearing was
simultaneously an ation of a real
question which is that same double
standard that you're describing right
that somehow it is tolerable to say
things about Jews that you couldn't say
about any other group or any other
minority um but at the same time the
grandstanding getting people to say
absurd things like yeah on our campus it
would depend on context well you know
the problem is that this hearing
involved grandstanding that created a
loophole that you could drive a truck
through which is you know if you were to
set up a um a historical debate right if
you were to let's say you were teaching
history and what you did was you set up
a historical debate amongst you know you
had students play the role of historical
people advocating for and against the
preservation of slavery right one of
those sets of people would be advocating
in a formal sense for slavery right that
would be their assignment and it is not
an unforgivable assignment right in
order for students to understand the
state of mind of that period in history
and advocacy for that period for that
abhorent position um that was
historically accurate would be a useful
tool do I you know relish the fact of
hearing people speak in such ways no but
from the point of view of what is a
valid College assignment that's very
different than somebody standing in the
quad and Dem demanding a return of
slavery both of them are technically
advocacy right and so um I'm I'm
frustrated that we are once again and in
fact at this moment the rise of this
very aggressive strain of anti-Semitism
which we are seeing which viewers of
Darkhorse will know that we've been
talking about since long before October
7th that the ability to properly
challenge that is being compromised by
the desire prior to
grandstand right um the in the same way
that the ADL
damaged um our ability to challenge
anti-Semitism by abusing the claim the
Anti-Defamation League Yeah by abusing
the claim and effectively crying wolf
over it now that we have a genuine wave
of of uh aggressive serious
anti-Semitism the ability to make that
claim and have people understand its
meaning is largely gone because because
they've heard that claim so many times
in so many contexts where it didn't
matter that um that it's lost its Punch
Yeah well and I mean to your point about
uh the educational value of
advocacy uh coming to inhabit a position
that is not
yours is absolutely excuse me being able
to come to inhabit a position that is
not yours is a mark of a mature mind a
wise mind an educated mind mind when
education meant that it brought you
closer to maturity and wisdom like this
is exactly what we need to do the idea
that
education now is only supposed to expose
you and allow you to communicate or
convey beliefs uh that are within a very
narrow bound of tolerated thought you
know the Overton window is the only
thing uh you know only those things
within it are those things which you are
allowed to speak to know to um refer to
that's not education and it's certainly
not wisdom and you know if if
that's if if that which is what we see
is happening is what is going on in
higher ed across the country and across
the world uh then we're generating
college graduates who are less and less
educated and so if these hearings were
happening in a context and you've
already said this but if these hearings
were H those exact words were said by
those exact you know Elite University
presidents MIT Harvard Penn right um in
a context in
which there were insane people arguing
for the genocide of black people and
that was being tolerated and there were
insane people arguing for the genocide
of trans people and that was being
tolerated there would be something to
discuss about how is it that these so
many people are so confused across so
many issues but at least there would be
a consistency around tolerating the
speech of people that you find hateful
yeah it um the speech that you find
hateful the problem for anybody who has
never tried to write one of these rules
yeah is that it is very hard to do well
right our first amendment is about as
good as you get and the point is our
first amendment leaves us perpetually
trip tripping over the fact that wait a
second you mean you're really going to
tolerate people seeing X or saying X
you're really going to tolerate people
saying why and the answer is yeah
because not tolerating it is way worse
right as soon as you say okay fine
you're right you've just described six
things that are completely intolerable
so let's just make a list of those six
and it's like seven yeah can we just go
it's at eight do I hear eight right and
so you know you could rerun it there's
actually a the next story we will
discuss there's a a wonderful deep fake
that has been done but in this case you
can imagine this hearing being deep
faked where the same people would be put
in the same positions and the you know
uh the Congress person would be
demanding you know are you saying it's
tolerable on Harvard's campus for
someone to claim that vaccines aren't
safe well that would depend on context
really that would depend on context for
people to be advocating for the idea
that vaccines are not safe in the middle
of a dangerous pandemic right you could
imagine that unfolding and you could
have you know again I don't think these
college presidents are honorable or be
honorable right to rise through the
ranks in such a corrupt system at this
point without becoming famous for uh
your courage in the face of the you know
idiocies of the moment right fact that
we find we discover these people at the
moment that they're being questioned on
this topic I have no doubt that this is
the double standard that appears to be
and that uh these people are you know
trying to thread a needle that is
basically an economic needle of how not
to piss off more donors than necessary
right this is a cynical game that's
unfolding but you could imagine that
once you establish the rule that here
are the seven things you're not allowed
to say on Harvard or pen or mit's campus
that of course what's going to get added
to that next it is going to be the
ability to claim uh something like a
quote unquote vaccine isn't safe which
means that there you know it was bad
enough it was almost impossible to say
that on these campuses uh during the
pandemic and you know lo and behold not
very much later the evidence is
overwhelming that that needed to be said
louder and that one of the greater
failings of modernity is that uh all of
these supposedly intelligent academics
who had uh all of this uh knowledge that
was supposed to allow them to see more
clearly than everybody else that they
were just signed up for a a political
program and a dangerous one at that
so at some level no but sorry no you go
ahead it I just keep coming back to it
it's the double standard it's like um
you insist on Nuance when someone has
the pronouns they don't prefer used with
them but you're going to embrace Nuance
when it comes to
genocide you got a double standard
problem and if we're going to focus on
only one of those things we're not going
to solve the problem like we we we need
we need the First Amendment back and we
need everyone to spend some time with it
and to actually consider what the
implications are
um yeah and I would I would add that
there's a yeah you're looking at my
notes that's not English no I can I got
it I'll tell you what that says and
you'll see that it's the intent is there
but um the uh we
are in this funny place where even the
question of a double standard is
something that we now trip over my claim
is going to be and I know you agree that
all of the Tyranny that has gone down is
basically built of double standards
right rules that are just unevenly
applied and that's how they that's how
the magic Justice for me and not for
thee right now the point is what you
want is and we've said this frankly we
said it I don't know how long Coleman
Hughes has been saying it but Coleman
Hughes got uh a huge bump in visibility
recently by saying that we need a
colorblind Society we've been saying
that forever that color blind is not a
matter of you've lost your ability to
detect that somebody is black or Asian
or whatever um but it's a matter of a
formal structure that is necessary so is
not to have a double standard having
noticed that noticing doesn't affect how
you treat them going forward right
everybody has yeah equal standing in the
eyes of the law and everywhere else um
but I would point out that one of the
things that we are tripping over here is
that there is a reason
to describe
anti-Semitism separately from other
kinds of races it is different right it
has a special status and you know you
can tell that by how it has recurred
through history right the way in which
targeting Jews keeps reemerging at
certain points in history and
manifesting in prgrams and genocide and
and all of these things um tells you
that it actually is of a special nature
now I don't think it's the only racism
that is of a special nature and people
who have followed us for the last six
plus
years will have heard me say many times
that I think there are actually two uh
populations in the US that experience a
distinct version of racism um a
structural one that is difficult to
overcome they are American blacks people
of African desent and American Indians
and yes American Indians do use that
term I'm not making a faux paw by using
it um those two groups experience
something very different their origin
story is different than but you're
talking specific specifically with
regard to the first group uh those who
were brought over against their will
you're not talking about the modern
children of immigrants for instance or
you know people who who come over um
freely from Africa well I would imagine
that it is a mixed bag because to the
extent that there is a special version
of racism that uh people who were
brought over against their will face
that lots of people are not
distinguishing between modern
African immigrants and people who derive
from that slave population and so my
guess is if you're a modern uh
American uh immigrant from Africa you um
there's certain aspects of this that you
don't face and there are other aspects
that you do just because people aren't
Discerning um but nonetheless the the
point is look there are there is a
general bigotry people don't like folks
who aren't like them and that's
something we largely got over as a
nation and we're now moving backwards um
and then there are special versions that
have to do with unique origin stories or
unique population structures the
diaspora nature of Jews I think is the
reason that Jews face repeated uh
flareups of genocidal
anti-Semitism which isn't the same thing
as just Garden variety anti-Semitism
both things exist but but in any case
there is reason to say actually do do
Indians do American blacks do Jews face
something different than the general
undercurrent of bigotry that has
characterized history yeah in all three
cases there's something to be talked
about that's distinct from the point of
view though of a structure like a
university should these things be
treated differently no they should not
what you want is a university system
that says here are the exact rules that
you will be held to here is the uh panel
that will be charged with evaluating
things that seem to fall into a gray
area and there's no way to write these
rules so there's no gray area except for
anybody is free to do anything at all
times including demand the genocide of
this that or the other group in the quad
you know while you know holding weapons
or I don't know whatever but um so what
we want is a system that's actually
sophisticated about
allowing uh um
honorable
explorations of any and all questions
and is good at protecting students from
uh being singled out for harassment and
unfortunately this hearing which could
have gotten to the point that these
universities are falling down on that
exact commitment failed to get there
because what it did is it got a sound
bite of three people saying something
that sounds extremely troubling but that
you know anybody who is both against
anti-Semitism and aware of the hazard to
free speech is caught in a bind between
these things so I guess one additional
Wrinkle in all of this uh in your
language just now you know what should
universities be be trying to do you use
the word honorable and the devil's
always going to be in the details right
you know how how do you define honorable
um you as as you pointed out it's
extraordinarily difficult to make a code
of conduct for student for faculty for
administration for you know any group of
people uh that is actually both General
enough to be meaningful and um and
precise enough um to well General enough
to to
not I don't even know exactly where the
risks are but but but but both General
and specific enough to be to be
effective um without treading on toes
that shouldn't be tread on um but
there's also the issue that uh this is
unfortunately very often these are um
students being led astray by um
ideologically captured faculty who
really ought to know better and this is
you know this is what we've been saying
for years and years and years but with
regard to the students only like The
Faculty need to know better ought to
know better and um they're are and
should be different rules for faculty
and
students but uh students
aren't expected to be wise yet that is
part of what they're supposed to be
doing in college is gaining wisdom and
the idea that they need to already know
all of the things uh that they will know
later on in life is akin to saying like
well then why are you here aren't aren't
haven't you already done what you need
to do and why don't you go out into the
world already and so you know we we have
to we have to leave students with room
to make errors and we have to leave all
of us with room to make errors but
students in particular are young and uh
and you know as you said on you know May
23rd 2017 when 50 students were sent by
confused faculty students we had never
met students we had never met were sent
by ideologically captured faculty um to
you know storm your classroom basically
um and people all over the
world saw what happened because the
students thought they were heroic and
uploaded what they did to um to the
internet people were impressed with how
calm you were and how reasonable and how
you engaged them like human beings calm
reasonable engag them like human beings
and as you
said uh to me and then I think to the
rest of the world well it's my job isn't
it to engage confused college
students make them less confused that is
like that is literally what we
understood our jobs as College
professors to be for those 14 15 years
to engage with confused college students
and to hopefully render them somewhat
less confused yep that that is the job
that is the job description and yes
there's other things involved as well
but like that is the job description and
so when confused and yes angry and you
know very very deeply confused students
show up on your door and they don't know
you um continuing with the job that you
already doing is actually what you
should be doing yeah I mean I I do think
that this is ex exactly why you and I
escaped the Calamity that had been
created to
swallos is that
simply doing the job because nothing was
different you know the fact that class
was declared over by these protesters
but they were on a topic that was
perfectly viable as an exercise um did
you know look who's brought curriculum
it's the protesters welcome yeah we and
you know the funny thing is we always
did allow people to sit in our classes
people brought friends and things and in
some ways this was a bunch of you know
this was a hostile takeover right but
yeah they still brought curriculum as
you say um now I was actually um
reminded of something from that episode
that I think fits perfectly in this
discussion which is that I
remember I don't remember exactly where
it happened it may be in that first
video in the hallway um but I remember
saying that we needed to put phenotype
aside my argument was it was exactly
this color blind argument we need to put
phenotype aside for the purposes of X Y
and Z and I remember a freak out over
the fact that I had used the word
phenotype totally remember this yes yeah
he said phenotype phenotype right and I
would point out well I mean this is the
exact problem is that a a discussion of
different
phenotypes is a discussion on which
there are no guardrails right in my
opinion as I've said many many times I
do not believe that there are important
cognitive differences that account for
the different levels of success of the
different populations in the West in the
US
that doesn't have to be right it is
possible and in fact I can prove that
important cognitive differences in
capacity must have existed historically
or prehistorically in our lineage they
must have existed in order for selection
to augment the cognitive capacity of the
creatures that we became of homo sapiens
right there had to have been differences
and creatures that had more capacity had
to have outcompeted creatures with less
capacity in order for us to have ended
up up here so that's the problem is that
you have to be able to have that
discussion and say there's nothing about
biology that prevents you from having
cognitive differences between
populations however I don't believe that
that's the explanation for the pattern
of the distribution of opportunity that
we currently see right that is not a
safe discussion and I could be wrong in
my conclusion right so the problem is if
phenotype becomes the indicator that you
are treading in territory that it cannot
be allowed because you might be a vile
racist or you might be a you know
whatever they're going to think you are
where you're going to end up putting
some Unthinkable but true fact on the
table right you there's no guardrail and
that's the nature of science that is the
nature of of the exploration for truth
so in effect what we're you know and it
goes back to um uh the codling of the
American mind point that you can't have
a university who is that is built built
to uh to establish social justice at the
same time that you have one that's built
to find truth you have to choose between
these objectives that's right um and
so we have to have the rules that allow
any and all discussions even though
there are a lot of those discussions
that aren't going to make decent people
happy right and I guess um normally this
might seem like uh taking the easiest
fruit first but um you the lowest
hanging fruit but you know to your point
about phenotype they gasped an alarm oh
my God he said phenotype I'm thinking of
a story from some years earlier at
Evergreen in which I lost an equally
stupid battle over a word um but I think
I and and at the time I saw it as the
craziness that it was and I'll and I'll
and I'll tell the story here but um I
think that having people start to clue
in that when people say oh could you
just not use that word um you know let's
use this word instead because that word
has a history like sometimes there will
be a word with a history that we don't
want to use anymore but very often now
this is the like the first line of
defense this is like the cudel that
keeps starts boxing you in you're like
okay now I'm actually not thinking as
clearly because there's a list of how
many words is it now it's not seven oh
it's 7,000 words I'm not supposed to use
and so I got to think in terms of what
am I allowed to say as opposed to I want
to just uh free associate and think
through ideas here and free associate
and think through ideas is what we're
supposed to be able to do right so um I
was in yeah some number of years before
Evergreen blew up uh in discussions to
teach a
program uh that had some anthropology
and some music and some Evolution and it
was going to be um focused you know this
isn't much of a focus but around
tropical regions of the world uh and you
know around which there's of course a
lot to a lot to say and one of the other
people involved one of the other faculty
was like yeah but we can't call it you
we're looking for a name because we've
already been discussions forever we're
looking for a name um we can't we can't
call it
Tropics like why why why can't we U well
because there's been a lot that's been
happening in the tropics that has been
um Colonial and and and and genocidal
and rapy and dangerous like true yes
true true that but it is also true true
that um the tropics is literally defined
a region of the earth that is defined by
the angle of the earth um you know
between 23.5 North and 23.5 South
degrees latitude uh and um that
astronomical reality if you will
actually doesn't change whether or not
you use the word tropics which is an
actual delineation of astronomical fact
or not um but I I lost we ended up
calling this this program equatorial
studies which is stupid because the
equator presumably also has had a
certain amount of uh Ridiculousness and
also were we ever talking about the line
that is the equator probably not no I
think no it's just a lie it's brilliant
because nothing bad has ever happened on
the equator because it can't it's a line
of zero Dimension now you could be on
both sides of the Equator simultaneously
and do something terrible you could but
yeah I think the equator itself is uh is
safe is safe by having zero zero
Dimension I'll bet I mean the Evergreen
Evergreen was weird because we did team
teaching and so that particular
experience may not be replicated many
many places but I'll bet anyone in FA in
on faculty who has sat in on faculty
meetings yeah has been privy to
discussions that are at least something
like that and most of if you're
listening to this you have probably
mostly rolled your eyes and just um you
know maybe been on your phone or you
know just waited for it to end
but you know within that small context I
fought back and still lost but the
fighting back over some iterated
conversations was useful because I was
able to see like what what is actually
at base of this like what what what does
he the faculty member in question think
is being solved here and I think that as
many when these things come up trying to
raise it to the level of like can you be
explicit about what your concern is uh
can actually reveal to them maybe but
especially to you what it is that we are
actually defending
against I think interesting
I don't think it's the only thing going
on but there's a hint here of the
reversal of purpose of these
institutions coming from the the the
market has overwhelmed their truth
seeking nature because uh while
universities especially these Elite ones
are about a lot of stuff including um
federal grants which provide a huge
fraction of their their operating budget
um they are also highly sensitive to
what their students want yeah because as
much as the institution is supposed to
be telling the students hey actually
here's what's good for you here are the
experiences that you should have that
will make you more capable uh when you
graduate the fact is the you know the
these students have gone from being
understood to be in need of cognitive
upgrade to the owners of the place they
are in position to dictate what they
will be taught and to say what they must
not be taught um and that that is an
absurdity but because no University
wants to be the place that students
don't want to go because they're going
to be forced to confront uh difficult
possibilities that violate the Notions
that they came through the door with the
universities are now um bending over
backwards not to confront them with
things they don't want to hear and I
would point out uh as i' as I've
mentioned other
times at Evergreen it used to be said it
was a cliche in
fact that it was our job to make
students uncomfortable right and that
literally stopped being said at some
point and for the last couple of years
that we were there I didn't hear a
single person say it whereas it was a
feature of almost every faculty meeting
that somebody would mention that
commitment before and so there was a
point at which you know some silence
coup took place and uh it was now
incumbent on us not to offend people um
and you can't that's not what a
university is right so in any case I
think I think we've made the point but
um college is a developmental experience
that's right if you come in if you leave
thinking what you thought when you went
through the door it failed right it
needs to confront you with things you
had not anticipated and it needs to
cause cause you to become not only
smarter but wiser and if it does neither
then uh it is quite literally a waste of
your money and your time importantly
yeah okay excuse me I want to spend a
couple
minutes on another video okay uh I for
reasons that have been lost to history
from like three days ago um decided uh
to search fizer on
YouTube and uh the very first video it
came up with uh
was
this well what is the title actually I
don't have the title in front of me the
title of the video is um here I can pull
it up it's called fizer's 2023 Global
diversity equity and inclusion Summit
inspires colleagues to accelerate
Equity it's a four and a half minute
video we're not going to show you the
whole thing uh and
just literally the first thing that
comes up when I Google when I when I
search in YouTube for fiser um just show
the first 52 seconds if you will a boss
gives answers and a leader seeks
Solutions a boss counts value and a
leader creates
value a boss has employees and a leader
motivates creates and inspires more
leaders
you see a leader remembers a leader
remembers that even when the storm has
tightened the chest of its people they
must plant themselves Strong by the
river that they must be witness and
Warrior to the moving mountains to the
turn in time that they must remind the
people to root themselves beside one
another that in order for us to breathe
with ease tomorrow each and every one of
you must remember that you are the
evidence of every
success so that was a professor of
English at
ruter
um quite quite a little speech that she
has given there I'm I am just stunned by
the everything about it but especially
the complete and utter meaninglessness
of what of what she has of what she has
said
um so that so as not to sh Force the
whole four and a half minutes on on
everyone um I want to share a few other
highlights from the video um says the uh
Chief Global diversity Equity inclusion
officer at fisa rames Jean Louie I don't
know if I'm pronouncing his name right
he says this is his third one of these
events he says every year is better than
the previous year we're going to
accelerate Equity we're going to push
the envelope I'm feeling excited about
the passion energy there's just all all
of this like corporate boardroom gobbly
G that means nothing right um he says
when we look at diversity equity and
inclusion not only do we look at it with
a holistic approach but we look at it
with a global lens wow yeah um he says
has fiser proud we're super proud
everyone is owning their own Dei
Journey they've got um my notes Here say
random black woman and random white
woman so I'm just going to go with it
they've a random black woman saying my
biggest takeaway is that there's still a
lot more that needs to be done there's
still a lot more education that we need
to continue to do immediately follows a
random white woman my biggest takeaway
is that there's so much more to do oh
they really seem like they're slam
dunking this stuff they just got so much
to do um and so back to that um that
English Professor from Ruckers she says
you are here even when your titles do
not shout it but because you believe in
it and finally the very end and um
because we are we are hope we are power
we are here thank
you I I encourage you guys to watch the
whole four and a half minutes but um
this feels like just this like perfect
Confluence of Dei nuttiness and Insanity
with big farma nut this insanity and
like who knew that they would put that
out into the world so neatly packaged
for us
demonstrating that they know I think
literally nothing about anything um and
just we're not going to show it but um
when that video finishes the next up
because YouTube of course also always
offers the next up what they offer is uh
Mission possible the race for a vaccine
a video from two years ago the very
first screen of which announces the
following National Geographic creative
Works program has paid content for and
in collaboration with
fiser and before the one minut minute
mark on this you know next up now that
you've watched how awesome fizer is on
Dei check us out on vaccines uh they
have borla the CEO CEO CEO of fiser
saying science is driving everything and
there were not many diseases there was
just one disease and our North Star
remains our faith in science like these
people are just saying whatever it is
that they are told to say and it either
means nothing or it's just flat out the
opposite of what they're actually
doing yeah
it the game of Pharma that we have
described here many
times is at best a purely mercenary
economic exercise in which the
destruction of innocent people is
neither here nor
there the idea that they are going to be
very concerned about diversity equity
and inclusion right that's the kind of
place they are you know this is uh this
is obvious nonsense if they were
actually concerned about anything in the
RA in the realm of values they would be
concerned about killing fewer people y
they would be concerned that you know
they would be concerned about minimizing
the harm of their products and to the
extent that that number couldn't be zero
it would they would be concerned about
taking care of those who got injured um
unavoidably and of course is concerned
about none of these things it is
concerned only about you know at best
some utterly diabolical bottom line in
which people are not an important factor
so what is even the purpose of these
videos of these
exercises and you know I'm caught in a
maze of different possibilities one is
the purpose of the videos is so that as
people are trying to figure out what to
think of about fizer's so-called
vaccines or whatever people who have a
diie
Dei um bent uh yeah either way works um
but people who have that bent in
Googling will find something that is the
equivalent of you know social justice
elevator music that cause them to feel
that this is their kind of company you
know oh social justice elevator music
that is perfect social justice elevator
music um but another possibility and I
think a certainty in fact is that fizer
is not going to be any better than any
of these other Mega corporations in the
sense that that it will be full of
people who literally do nothing
identifiable from the point of view even
for fizer's diabolical Mission yeah
right these people will just be dead
weight there'll be nothing you can do
about them there's not a single idea in
that entire video right there's there's
nothing on offer there is nothing there
is nothing on offer and um that isn't
surprising in this era and I mean the
main the the the the speaker from ruers
who's not at fizer this professor at
ruers um who they clearly are showcasing
like you know she like it says she's a
professor of English it sounds like just
I mean it's literally empty rhetoric yep
you know she has this oratorical style
and she knows how to pause in the in the
like in the framing of like spoken word
poetry um but you listen to the actual
words a boss gives answers and a leader
seeks
Solutions a boss counts value and a
leader creates value it none of it means
anything right and you know you could be
you could you could replace the nouns
with anything you like like everything
could be replaced with other things and
it would still be English and still
equally meaningful meaningless yeah and
you know we are if this is is not
already and presumably it's not but if
this is not already effectively
AI um you know generating this stuff so
that it will uh you know tug on the
heartstrings of those who aren't quite
paying attention um it will be soon and
it will be absolutely indifferent to
topic it will be you know you're the
kind of person who likes this sort of
stirring speech and so we've created
this thing and we're going to put it
right where people who have your bias in
this regard are going to stumble onto it
and feel like hey yeah that's the stuff
yeah man that really sounds good Zach
had something to offer yeah it just
strikes me that uh in a classroom
everybody would feel a little bit
ashamed if they add a little bit of
fluff to their essay or speech or
whatever just a little bit to make it
longer a few words that mean nothing at
all and the people who apparently have
no shame whatsoever have ended up in the
highest positions and you know have put
together just a string of words it's not
like there's some idea that they've
added a little bit around there's just
nothing there from the beginning there's
nothing there from I mean I I know we we
played it for you but I you see Alita
remembers that even when a storm has
tightened the chest of its people they
must plant themselves Strong by the
river that they must be witness and
Warrior to the moving mountains to the
turn in time that they must remind the
people to root themselves besides one
another that in order for us to breathe
with ease tomorrow every one of you must
remember that you are the evidence of
every success Zig I mean hell
yeah it's Insanity yeah it's it's
unbelievable but okay back to back to
the initial topic
right what this requires is a group of
people who were supposed to be educated
and weren't yes right if you had to go
through some structure where University
decided to abdicate responsibility for
making you smarter and wiser and instead
Embrace whatever you thought coming
through the door better than the
competing University M right this is
what you get you get a world full of
people who can't think won't think think
they're doing the thing by showing up
and you know rallying at the correct
moment and presumably this reminds them
exactly of college because there's a
college professor doing what college
professors now do and these are the
people in the audience who were like the
big wigs in Dei at fizer um going like
yes yes ma'am yeah all right so the
whole thing is now sort of falling into
place um the job of a parent is actually
to model the world that a child will
become an adult in so that the child has
good circuitry for knowing how to work
in it that has fallen apart right we now
have some dumb notion that uh childhood
is about innocence and we're supposed to
protect our children from everything
while they're growing up and then
they're magically going to be able to
manage risk when they get into the real
world and they can't um but the point is
this thing keeps extending right parents
are supposed to model the world that the
child is going to be an adult in at some
point formal education is not supposed
to load in The Facts of Life it is
supposed
to provide developmental exposure and
experiences that continue to elaborate
the capacity of that mind beyond what
the parent in the home could have done
right into Realms the parent won't be
able to access and it is supposed to
produce people who stand up at meetings
like this and say actually that doesn't
sound like anything at all to me here's
what I'm really concerned about with
respect to diversity equity and
inclusion here's what I'm not concerned
about and it doesn't seem to me like
we're even interested in what part of
this is true right right so the point is
that's not going to happen in fact that
person's going to get fired right that
person is not even going to get to the
point of being fired because they're
going to be spotted on the way in and
they're going to be you know uh sent a
form letter yeah so you know we have a
whole system that's built to um to
suffuse itself with this like I don't
even know what to call it it's like Gap
filling foam right that looks corporate
when it's supposed to and looks academic
when it's supposed to it's social
justice great stuff it's social justice
social justice great stuff and you'll
realize what that means when you get it
on your
hands great stuff uh you're going to
have to Define what great stuff is great
stuff is you said social justice
elevator music it's both it's social
justice great stuff and social justice
elevator music so great stuff I will I
will tell you um my encounter my first
encounter with great stuff when it was
brand new um it is a gap filling foam
that you buy at the hardware store in a
can in a can uh it comes with a straw
and you inject it into a gap that you
want filled now so it looks it it's like
a can of WD40 but um yeah there it is
yeah now here's the thing you need to
know about great stuff is you really
need somebody to walk you through how it
goes wrong in order for you to be able
to use it in the ways that you should
use it because it really is fantastic
okay when it's the product you need it's
exactly what you want but if you don't
know anything about how this product
works your first mistake is going to be
painful um so my first mistake I got
this stuff and I filled the Gap I was
trying to fill I can't remember where it
was and it started you know expanding in
a way that's very surprising ing even if
you have read the can which I did but um
yeah it's the Tardis of Hardware
products it it expands like crazy and
you have to not panic at that first of
all you have to put in only enough that
the amount of expansion is tolerable and
there's a way to deal with the part that
expands out of the space that you were
trying to fill very elegant way of
dealing with it but you need to know
that you're going to get that chance
later when it's not wet anymore and if
you start panicking at the way it it
starts emerging from this crack you're
going to get it all over your hands and
then you're going to discover that is
made of an epoxy that bonds brilliantly
to your hands and then you're going to
try to get it off and you're going to
get all kinds of dirt into it and you're
going to be stuck with dirt epoxy to
your hands unlike if you left it in
place you can't take a um a blade to
your hands as neatly as you can to the
wood where the Gap used to be and is now
filled with great stuff ex and I I think
my error the first time I used the stuff
uh we were going somewhere
out of characteristic we were going
somewhere relatively formal and so I had
gotten it all over my hands and there
was no getting it off in time um so
everyone who shook your hands like what
is with that guy's skin I have uh I have
eliminated those memories so I do not
have to relive them but um but anyway
great stuff is is a space filling foam
and corporations are now full of the
equivalent so my analogy I think social
justice elevator music is is brilliant
social justice great stuff has one
weakness in the analogy at least which
is that with great stuff if you put in
too M put on too much which you almost
always will um the thing to do is to
back away and not mess and let it settle
and then come back later and clean it up
uh and if we back away and do not mess
and let it settle when it's the social
justice stuff well that's what we're
living now because too many people did
not did that we're like ah not my
problem I I don't want to deal with that
I got it yeah it's not great stuff it's
not great stuff it's
Tribbles social justice tribles yes okay
okay Zach does not know that reference
Zach does not know that reference so he
can't show us a picture of the there is
an episode of the original Star Trek
called The Trouble with Tribbles MH and
Tribbles were utterly adorable furry
pet-like Critters so cute that somehow
in a way that contravenes any reasonable
notion of um physics and energetics um
and selection yeah uh comes to drown the
Enterprise in great picture of Captain
Kirk yeah good picture of Captain Kirk
um so anyway yeah social justice tribles
is uh is what we got and they are
destroying every corporation University
newspaper uh social hear the triples I
mean I don't think the triples talked
but the triples being like we are hope
we are power we are hope we are are here
we are standing by the river thank
you
yeah okay maybe we're done with that
yeah I think I think we explored it I I
I think so too um you wanted to talk
about Elon Musk and Disney and uh and
that whole situation yeah I did um and I
will say that for a thorough explanation
I assume that most of our viewers will
have seen video of Elon we're going to
show it here in a second um but we'll
have seen video of Elon being uh
interviewed um about his approach to the
ad advertising conundrum at
Twitter um for a fuller exploration of
this topic I would advise people to look
at Paul D ther's sub screen here which
is called the disinformation chronicle
in which he
explores um this in great depth anyway
uh I quite like Paul and I quite like
the substack so anyway that we'll put
the link in the description but I would
suggest for a deeper dive go there now
Zach do you want to show the video of uh
Elon being uh
interviewed what was that trip like and
obviously you know that there's a public
perception that and and you're
clarifying this
now um but there's a public perception
that that was part of a apology tour if
you will that this had been said online
there was all of the criticism there was
advertisers leaving we talked to Bob
Iger stop you hope uh don't advertise
you don't want them to advertise no what
do you
mean if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go
yourself but go
yourself is that clear
all right so um the reason to raise this
is that I don't think we know where we
are exactly um but it is potentially an
important turning point it's not the
first one of these musk staring down the
ADL when they tried to shake him down
earlier and he now telling Bob Iger of
Disney uh to go f himself um if he was
going to try to muscle musk using um the
threat to pull advertising and and all
of that um is a likely an indicator of a
new chapter and it's actually a chapter
that follows from something that we've
been saying very early on people will
remember we have said zero is a special
number zero is a special number for
those who are uh new to it it means that
there is a game theoretic requirement to
shut down any and all challenges to
certain structures if there is a single
uh newspaper that is reporting
accurately or attempting to report
accurately on the the unfolding of
History then of course you'd be a fool
to subscribe to any other newspaper
everybody's going to want that one
newspaper so that means the number of
such newspapers if you're going to sell
false stories has to be zero one
newspaper is enough to change the entire
landscape likewise one University that
didn't um infantilize your uh your kids
when you sent them to college would
immediately be the best university in
the country uh or in much of the western
world so there must be zero universities
that do that job in order for your child
to end up infantilized in exactly the
desired Ways by the power structure and
this appes Li to social media platforms
so my claim is that by purchasing
Twitter musk opened the door to actually
freeing the Public Square even though
Twitter is comparatively small in terms
of its user base a single platform in
which we were free to talk about what
might be true and explore it um as
experts and people who are interested in
these questions is enough to game
theoretically turn the tide on the
entire puzzle and that is why he is
being targeted very directly
which um musk says and he also uh Paul
fer in his substack points to a tweet
from uh
2022 um yeah if you scroll down you'll
see it there it is I think um in which
musk uh you want to put put that out I
got it he says you want me to read it
yeah in the past I voted Democrat
because they were mostly the kindness
party but they have become the part
party of division and hate so I can no
longer support them and will vote
Republican now watch their dirty tricks
campaign against me unfold that was musk
tweeting on May 18th
2022 right so this is him anticipating
that his move is not simply an economic
move that he is effectively declared war
on a narrative control structure and the
next move of that narrative control
structure is absolutely guaranteed that
there will be a dirty tricks campaign
designed to make him look uh crazy to
make him uh look racist to make him look
all the things that would cause everyone
who would otherwise associate with him
or be willing to participate or be
willing to stay on uh Twitter and see
how things unfolded make them all feel
that there's something too dangerous to
to embrace and to back away right
effectively an isolation campaign y
um and uh the idea first of all um musk
I haven't tracked whether he has
remained the most wealthy uh person on
Earth but he was at least recently the
most the wealthiest person on Earth and
I think he still remains that and even
if he's second who cares if anybody has
you money it would be Elon Musk and
here he is literally embracing that
posture and confronting
a uh an economic Goliath Disney who is
threatening his investment right musk
has made a $44 billion investment in
Twitter why would you do that because
zero is a special number and so you know
you can make an argument for that being
a purely uh economic move in other words
uh because zero is a special number if
you manage to create the exception then
business-wise it's going to draw a
tremendous amount of audience and we saw
a lot of back and forth people you know
arranging uh an exodus from Twitter and
all of that but the question really it
all seemed very performative it was very
performative and it was tactical I would
I would love data that tells us how many
people actually left without announcing
it like what what was the actual Exodus
in terms of the user base not in terms
of the employees but the user base right
um I I think a couple of things are true
we know this because musk has said them
one he fired a large fraction of the
workforce and Twitter did not collapse
that's the employee base it's different
that goes to the question of was Twitter
full of a lot of dead weight that was
not necessary to run it but also the um
various measures that suggest how
healthy Twitter is um
userbase uh hours that people spend on
it um the breadth of the circulation are
all in a positive direction so it's not
to say that there aren't things to
complain about and of course you know I
still
feel the weight of some sort of cryptic
deboosting uh I don't know if it's
algorithmic or I don't know if there are
moles inside the thing but I guess I
wonder um what you just said I I don't
know the data you're talking about um
amount of time spent on the thing
presumably from Twitter's perspective
positive means more yes um but for the
users that's worse for mental health in
general yeah I mean musk has been pretty
clear about this that um he's not
obviously at a business level um he has
a um a a conflict of interest which is
he wants uh Twitter to be healthy
irrespective of its effect on its users
but he has been explicit about the fact
that he wants the time that is spent
there not to be time that is regrettable
and regretted um so I mean look I don't
know if musk Is For Real as I keep
saying I will point out uh again at the
moment for whatever reason musk has me
blocked which frankly is very annoying
because he does so much on the platform
that then affects what people say I
can't even see those conversations I
don't know for sure that it's even him
who's initiated these conversations I
have to jump through lots of Hoops even
to see it so you know it's not that um I
don't have misg givings about him and I
do have one fear that I will just simply
put on the table because somebody has
to there are two ways to interpret the
game theory around creating a social
media platform in which speech is free
one of them is that he is doing exactly
what he says he's doing which is what I
think he is up to which is he is trying
to liberate it because it will be a good
thing Not only would it be a good thing
at the level of the health of his
investment but it will also be a good
thing for planet Earth to have a place
that we can talk talk openly about the
important issues of the
day the possibility that I think those
of us who think game theoretically have
to be open to is that it would also be
an extremely shrewd move to level a
credible threat of free speech and then
monetize a
retreat I don't think this is what he's
doing a credible threat I don't think I
understand the framing of what you just
said if if there's a if Goliath wants to
control narratives because Goliath has
plans for us all that uh he does not
want us to openly discuss if you were to
create the possibility of a newspaper or
a university or a social media platform
in which speech was going to be free
Goliath would wet himself so it's a
threat to Goliath it's not a threat to
the rest of us right no it is it is a
service the rest didn't understand the
but the point is were're musk completely
cynical and I don't think he is but were
he completely cynical then creating the
possibility of a free speech environment
and then saying presumably behind closed
doors what's it worth to you not to see
that thing mature right right um that
would be certainly a possibility it is
at least formally a possibility um but
what we see in that video where musk uh
basically I love that he mocks the idea
of using a monetary threat to muscle him
because if one person right has enough
money to stare down such a threat it's
musk which doesn't mean that they
couldn't take him out of the position of
world's wealthiest person knock him down
to 50th but the point is at what point
does a guy like musk actually um feel so
impoverished that uh that it's it will
in his mind have been a mistake and the
answer is this is a weird person this is
a person who actually um you know a he
is far busier than almost anybody on
Earth maybe he is the busiest person on
Earth at least with respect to
meaningful
stuff okay he if he wanted to relax and
you know go hang out in cool places with
awesome people he could do that for the
rest of his life without producing
anything new so the point is if this
were a hedonist he would be doing
something very different now he does
obviously like to win and this is an
audacious play in which he could lose
spectacularly by saying you know that
his advertisers don't have control over
him he could also win spectacularly and
what the Hope has to be for people like
us who want a free internet where we can
discuss important things is that his
desire to win and his desire to make the
world better are in alignment that there
there's not a conflict between those
things that actually um you know what
motivates him uh works for both both uh
objectives and
um let's hope that that's what's going
on but this is a good sign I think a
public confrontation that puts
advertisers on notice that it is not
true that uh your investment in uh
economic power uh means that you can
make some phone calls and get what you
want in the case of an unusual person
like musk it doesn't mean that and um a
lot of us who are just simply not in a
position to fight back in any meaningful
way against a a Goliath like Disney um
are you know are on board for a reason
right so this is a battle in which we
have everything at stake and uh it
appears that somebody is is fighting on
our behalf so let's hope that's what it
is yeah uh and I guess I would say that
um what is actually true at Disney is of
course a question as well and given what
we saw of from that fiser video about
what's going on with the Dei Shenanigans
at fiser and what we know is going on at
the institutions of higher ed of higher
ed and which is not revealed by the
questioning by the representative from
New York but um we know is um a double
standard being revealed by the answers
by the presidents of Penn and MIT and
Harvard uh that you know
something at Disney is probably still
alive and interested in Creative
exploration and almost certainly that
thing um is not in charge and there's
just just like there was at Twitter and
there is in almost every organization of
any size at all there's presumably just
a ton of personnel at Disney who are
actually making some policy but actually
have nothing to offer the world and so
you know why is it that Disney you know
made this pronouncement in the first
place and basically tried to tried to
move the needle against musk well that
was as it turned out probably ill you
know certainly ill advised but um you
know probably came from some of these
you know middling you know I want almost
said midwit it's just not really a term
I I love but um these are you know
middle
manager probably mostly recent gra
recently graduated or if they're not
recently gradua from college they're
older and they're scared and they just
want to hang on and not lose their jobs
people who aren't standing for anything
anymore so like could everyone please
like look inside yourself and figure out
what you actually stand for at whether
or not whatever thing you're trying to
preserve be you know your your pension
your health insurance and your income
like whatever it is is it worth it to
have given up everything else like do
you stand for anything anymore or are
you willing to continue to spend your
days listening to this crap and and
helping move it forward in the world and
and having you know Disney become
nothing and you know the pharmaceutical
companies are you know doing evil one
moment and then doing the work of what
you know the Dei is like being allowed
to run the world with its in insipidity
can we do insipidity I'm going to have
to look that up well it's in insipidity
it's insipidity yeah uh anyway well um I
want to put it in a slightly different
context hearing you describe it this
way obviously it will not be the first
time anybody's invoked religion here
yeah but I
feel like what we've
seen is a
a blue a left
religion that has infused itself
into many corporations it's infused
itself you know just like uh you know
folks on the right gained a lot of power
by getting themselves on school boards
and things um
this is folks on the nomal in like back
in like the 80s 90s yeah this is folks
having quietly taken over um all of the
institutions of a certain stripe which
is then allowing them to mint new
members of their religion because if you
go through college you know you'd have
to you'd have to be pretty clever to
avoid getting Dragged In on the nonsense
um and so now that you know if this was
Scientology if Scientology had infused
itself self into the institutions in
such a way that it was now speaking
through the CEOs of you know Exxon and
and uh Disney and and visor and the New
York Times right and you know and the
the minions of these corporations were
gathering in rooms hearing about the
sacred doctrines of you know zenu or
whatever right then the rest of us
normies could spot it right it would be
obvious what was going on and be like I
don't know exactly what to do about the
fact that Scientology has just taken
over all of these power structures um
but the fact is but the only I think the
only reason that the rest of us that the
rest of the people could spot it is
because in in the timeline that you've
created this would be happening after
the world has already heard of and
decided to publicly uh recognize that
Scientology is is worse than woo right
so it everyone imagines they will see
the thing we are now living through
proof that most people can't see the
thing when it happens yeah and and uh in
part it's because people actually
believed their history classes like oh
what you do is you read about the thing
in the book and it's all very clear-cut
because the enemies wear masks and maybe
they have capes behind them and the
superheroes have like things on their
chests and they fly or they have amazing
powers and so you know and so you know
what side of History you're on and you
know what to do because you know so it
is written and that's not actually what
it is to live life like you sometimes
you run into something that does really
look like things looked before you know
when the you know the wh- hooded idiots
come walking down the street you know
what that is y there's a reason that's
not mostly what it looks like now yeah
it doesn't it doesn't work anymore
because we can all see it the thing that
we can all see is too easy to respond to
and so the fact that you're not
responding is no evidence at all that
there's nothing to respond to it may
actually be the opposite right it's the
opposite this is clearly a religious
move movement and that religious
movement you know what is the religious
movement that unites an um obscene
blindness to pharmaceutical hazards with
a uh
a commitment to the idea that racism is
um suffused through every instit
institution and is aggressively shaping
society that connect that to a
willingness to tolerate um contemplation
of genocide against Jews yeah right what
is that religion oh uh coupled with a uh
belief that there is some sacred Essence
inside of children that allows them to
declare themselves the opposite gender
from their morphology and therefore that
we uh must sacrifice their reproductive
capacity and Sexual Health uh in order
to Aid them to look like the thing that
they may or may not have suggested they
have some affinity for right the point
is that's a whole bunch of religious
Doctrine yes and it's religious doctrine
of a religion that doesn't acknowledge
that it is a religion which makes it
especially
dangerous and the point is what has it
got oh my God has it got a huge amount
of power and wealth and access to
frankly all of our emails all of are you
know phone conversations it has access
at will to the um Communications and
thought processes of its enemies and its
enemies are the people who believe in
the values of the West the values that
um that religion has just pulled a huge
population away from yeah so I do think
that that's where we are um and the
problem is we're not
allowed to the extent that we say that
this is religious you know that the the
belief that men can become women is a
religious belief or uh the adherence to
the idea that the covid so-called
vaccines were safe is a kind of a
religious Faith um the point is we think
we're speaking by loose analogy and
increasingly I think we are talking
about something that is literally a
religion in every respect but one that
it doesn't call itself
that's it the only thing that's not
standard fair is the um the and actually
I say one other thing uh just to be
consistent with the epistemology we've
put forward here many times you can't
start a new religion you can start a
cult and then selection can decide
whether your cult has any value at all
and if it does it can shape it into a
religion through selection this is cult
well I wonder if it's not
you know if we're talking about
Origins there's something shared between
all of the things you've talked about
and just to pick the two most recent
ones you've talked about the idea of a
gender Essence within each child and the
idea that the um covid so-called
vaccines uh were safe and
effective
those don't appear to have emerged from
the same
people they don't appear to have emerged
from the same um
epistemological
confusions but they use exactly the same
tools to get people to buy into them and
so I wonder if it's not actually that we
have multiple Cults all of which are
converging on these same tools and then
the Cults basically are aggregating and
they will they they are acting together
as one as one religion and it is true
that people who believe in gender
Essence um are
I think it's extremely likely to be true
that people who believe in gender
Essence are more likely to have said um
yes not only to shots one and two but to
shots three and four during Co then
people who were like gender Essence what
no I don't think so who were more likely
to be skeptical of um at least the
boosters if not the vaccines in the
first place so you know the the
different Cults have similar affinities
in some way but I'm not I don't think it
doesn't emerge as a single thing and so
it's not exactly a religion well I don't
know I I don't know I I think yes the
fine details of how this happened how
what I'm saying is a a broad cult with
various sets of beliefs on different
topics obviously didn't emerge in the
same way that um you know let's take
Scientology as a as a competing example
where you have a found I don't know
really anything about it so but well you
have a Founder you have Elon hubard who
spells out a bunch of stuff and it
becomes you know there is a single
Inception point and everything scient
comes from that this obviously is
different um than that but I would
say the cult in question
is you know why are there pharmaceutical
beliefs uh coupled with gender Essence
beliefs well actually there's one
obvious reason that there would be
because this is tremendously lucrative
for Pharma as you've pointed out many
times and you're the first person to
point it out uh in my
awareness um but you know why would that
be connected
to uh A Renewed belief in an aggressive
form of racism pervading all
institutions well
because the New York Times and I don't
want to blame the New York Times
uniquely because obviously the LA Times
is on the same page as is the Chicago
Tribune and all the others right um but
effectively the New York Times is like
the daily
encyclical right the daily encyclical
puts out the present status of beliefs
for the cult and occasionally there's a
major admission occasionally the New
York Times is forced to acknowledge you
know just the same way that the Catholic
church was forced to acknowledge first
that the um Earth went around the Sun
and then later and actually not much
later in history from the point of view
of the acknowledgement um to knowled
that uh the theory of natural selection
um was I believe their language was not
just a theory but or was more than a
theory but in fact to acknowledge that
there is deep reality there yeah um the
point is in cyclical one of the things
they do is um
backpedal former errors and so the New
York Times can be forced to acknowledge
that they've made errors on things like
lab leak mhm um but nonetheless that's
really its purpose is to tell the
faithful here is the present status of
beliefs and you should um you know your
God will be very upset with you if you
violate these um things which is why you
don't find people um who subscribe to
part but not the whole of the set of
doctrines if you're constantly having
there are some there are a few no I
think I think there's I I think you know
co co co broke people's
minds well Co now because people's
personal health was put in Jeopardy and
many many people were injured in ways
that are unignorable it has woken people
up in part but I think in general the
willingness to accept this um was fed
through that same channel in the same
way and it was reality that woke people
up I'm actually I'm talking about the
other direction I'm it's it's not just
the famously confused people I just
think I know there are a lot of people
who are awake to gender Essence is
and um no not all white people
are racist and you and and Dei
everywhere is actually getting in the
way of a meritocracy um who uh actually
are mostly buying into the standard Co
line still and you know but you know
without probably taking boosters anymore
yeah that's the thing I don't think but
they it's just kind of quite like no
it's fine yeah they' never formally
revised their position which um is
frustrating and in fact while I was away
it occurred to me there are a couple
things that work this way and it
suggests a a characterological defect
that I want to call out I don't know
what its name should be but that folks
who went after um their friends and
family and neighbors over covid
Orthodoxy who have now stopped getting
their boosters quietly without
acknowledging that they reversed
position strike me as very much
like um folks of the left who uh
destroyed good governance in the western
states and then moved to Texas right I
get it that you moved to Texas but you
owe us an acknowledgement that you
screwed up and that what you did was you
you know you poisoned your home well and
now you've bought into somebody else's
well um but it's it's the same thing
right the the failure to acknowledge
that you've um reversed course is ging
and it needs to
be um it needs to be called out yeah um
just one more point on this since we're
talking about cults and religions uh and
just a shout out to Zach if you would
show my screen um the newest Robert galb
novel which is Robert galri is JK
rowlings um n de plume can't believe
you've outed JK
ring I think she only wrote one of these
um under the pseudonym before it was
known but anyway it's 10 years ago now
so it's it's so you've outed her but not
no I have not outed her not outed her
she Ed herself I believe I actually I
don't remember I was I wasn't reading
them back then I didn't know about these
books I just discovered these books last
year and the 7th one has just come out
in September of this year and um it's
fantastic I'm as everything that she
writes is and this is a detective series
uh in which the two the two main uh
characters are we find them throughout
uh and in each one they're taking on
some giant case uh and this one has at
the center of its story a cult religion
uh that draws people in and I I know I
suspect it's it's at least
Loosely after Scientology because
there's like a famous novelist who's
part of it and there's a famous factors
that's part of it and uh and you know
what happens to the the normies who get
pulled in and um you know aren't you
know their families can't find them
anymore their trust funds are spent down
um they you know entirely change what
they look like and of course um what
they think uh it is an
extraordinary
investigation it's beautifully written
it's fiction you know so if if if that's
all you need like read it anyway but um
it's just it's a very deep analysis of
the Thinking Inside Cults which it
doesn't really surprise me that she
would be excellent at that but uh if
anyone is looking for such a thing I
highly recommend this book it's called
The Running grave of the seventh yeah
actually um that's interesting I
obviously haven't read it uh but
the there's a lot about JK
rling that I may be mispronouncing that
is it rolling I think it may be rolling
and I started it like you anouncing it
how I did yeah I'm just following suit
man but um whoever she is uh yeah
there's a lot about the Harry Potter
series that stood to be potentially
extremely important in disempowering the
cult that we are hypothesizing here
absolutely and so the cult went after
her yeah on the basis of supposed
transphobia which is of course fictional
right um but the you know the Death
Eaters are Ault and yes it's done in a
way that a child can understand it but
it certainly there's a reason that a lot
of adults liked that series too and it's
because actually a lot of these
uh processes and coalitions that are
made fanciful in the Harry Potter series
map very well onto real structures and
behaviors and so anyway it's no it let's
put it this way it would be difficult to
pull off what they are pulling off if
they had not figured out a way to
compromise JK Rowling um well it's got
to be just
about I mean there's so many ways that
what is happening to her is awful and
you know she's not as hurt as Elon Musk
but she's got an extraordinary amount of
power and wealth and so and she has she
has not told Disney to off um but
she has um told some number of of people
who would cancel her to you know that
they know where they can put their
complaints
um
she I was I just G I totally lost track
of what I was going to say about um her
saying it was necessary to get rid of it
was necessary to compromise her Legacy
in order yeah for the uh yeah so um you
know you've got like the actors from the
films and these just you Legions of fans
who go to Potter conferences and and
whatever who are claiming that you know
who are actually getting rid of her name
like I think there's a Harry there's
either a Harry Potter Museum or a big
exhibit at some massive Museum where her
name has actually been stricken from it
like these people are nuts right and
that's got to be painful enough for a
Creator yes but I think actually more
painful by far is you completely
misunderstood the books like this thing
that you lame to have you know found
your identity through and figured out
your reson Detra and like this is what's
driving you you clearly understood
nothing and those were some of the
biggest fans like no I assure you there
are plenty of us out here who got it or
got some of it there's so much in her
books right who got some of it enough of
it and can see that what is happening
was practically
predicted right once again Monty Python
has anticipated this how was
that you don't need to follow anyone
you're all individuals we all
individuals I'm
not yep yep
y okay um can we talk about penguins
briefly uh let's do that yeah let's talk
about penguins briefly so last week um
we talked about penguins and it was
those course obviously and I don't think
this is going to become a trend because
frankly how much can you say about
penguins alien all of the penguin lovers
in the audience including my mother
which is terrible um no there's actually
there's a lot to say about penguins we
don't we've never no we have seen them
in gagos but um that's the only species
we've seen we don't know a ton about
them I just happen to have run across
it's kind of a low rent penguin galpagos
yeah I know that's the penguin I'd want
to be if I got to choose well I agree um
from The Point Let's uh let's put it
this way the galpagos penguin has a
great personality I feel like the real
estate Antarctica has got to be cheaper
no I agree with I well that's true I
mean you literally said low rent well
but okay but history of the galpagos
right remember that until um Darwinism
made The galpagos Marvelous nobody
wanted it so it is it is kind of um yes
but Antarctica was not even under
discussion right that's true no there's
a couple Flags been planted and at this
point some building it wasn't even on
Zillow right there it just wasn't it
wasn't worth posting it really not yeah
really not um but from the point of view
of looks um the the galopagos penguin
does have a marvelous
personality I think he's charming and
he's Charming but he's kind of a dirty
looking penguin he's not brilliant white
and black you know true okay fair enough
fair enough um so last week we talked
about uh I can't even remember which
penguin it was some some species of
penguin um that could tell individuals
apart on the basis of their um their
ventral markings their chest markings
they're dots and dashes as you said and
um this week um in
science uh I run into a piece called um
well actually yeah the original research
is in science and it's also reported on
in science news uh nesting here hold on
I got to open up the right thing here we
go uh nesting chin you can open up my
screen here nesting chinstrap Penguins
acre large quantities of sleep through
seconds long micro sleeps let me read
the abst
micro sleeps the seconds long
interruptions of wakefulness by eye
closure and sleep related brain activity
are dangerous when
driving and might how much driving do
these penguins do this exactly my
question thank you and what are they
driving at I don't I probably just to
get the fu out of Antarctica yeah these
ones are in Antarctica these are chin
strap penguins in Antarctica um are
dangerous when driving and might be too
short to provide the restorative
functions of sleep certainly if you're
driving it's not very
restorative if microsleeps do fulfill
sleep functions then animals fac with A
continuous need for vigilance might
resort to this sleep strategy we
investigated electroen wow that went
longer than I was expecting we
investigated
electroencephalographically defined
sleep in Wild chinstrap penguins at Sea
and while nesting in Antarctica
constantly exposed to an egg predator
and aggression from other Penguins the
skua is the egg Predator another bird
the skua the Penguins noted off more
than 10,000 times per day individual
that's not like the whole Colony
individual penguins kned off more than
10,000 times per day engaging in bouts
of bi hemispheric and uni hemispheric
slow wave sleep lasting on average only
four seconds on average only 4 seconds
but resulting in the accumulation of
more than 11 hours of sleep for each
hemisphere per day the investment in
micro sleeps by successfully breeding
Penguins suggests that the benefits of
sleep can occur incrementally now you
said that they
are gaining the benefits of sleep in
both hemispheres they're not even in the
northern
hemisphere
sorry again though I'm going to direct
you the like I didn't write the I'm just
a messenger here yeah um no they're not
even in the um northern hemisphere so
yes I mean questions raised are of
course how what do penguins Drive yes
why do they
drive there's bound be a funny answer to
that I can't think of it yeah probably
is yeah um so let me just just you know
limitations um and here here's just
something about methods which also
reveals a main limitation which is uh
and you can show my screen if you want
but you don't have to again from the
main paper We examined sleep We examined
sleep in 14 Penguins so it's not a huge
n it's a small sample size We examined
sleep in 14 Penguins incubating eggs in
a colony during early December 2019
using data loggers we measured sleep
related EEG activity from both cerebral
hemisphere spes the electromyogram from
the neck muscles body movements and
posture with accelerometry location with
GPS and diving with a pressure sensor so
part of what they're saying there is we
were we were trying to find we were
trying to use a bunch of measures of
sleep and at some level what this
research raises the question it raises
for me is are we defining sleep
correctly right so you know are these
measures these basically these EEG
activity measures uh which are again on
average 4 seconds long in these chin
strap chin strap Penguins but when you
add those up over the course of 10,000
of these events in a day on average to
more than 11 hours of this so-called
sleep in a day that's still a lot of
sleep uh but one of one of the
interesting things about this research
is um that of course vigilance is raised
as a reason for sleep to be disrupted
and for individuals uh or individuals
across an entire species to perhaps
sleep um in smaller bouts rather than
extended bouts like like we tend to um
but this research suggests that um you
know they do these these big Colony
nesting things and as you would expect
the skuas the the predator birds um are
they're they're they're there they're
there all the time and the attacks tend
to come at the edges of the colony
because why would you go into the middle
when you could go to the edge but uh
they actually find deeper longer sleep
in the penguins at the edges of the
colony than in the middle of the colony
the Penguins in the middle of the colony
have more shorter bouts of sleep than
the penguins at the edge of the colony
suggesting that either we've totally
missed something they have to be
vigilant about or it's not vigilance
that is driving the the micro
sleeps H okay that the reason for that I
can't even think of one but yeah I don't
I don't have it either it's it's it's
the it's the one thing I ran into in
this was like that's that's just that's
exactly counter what the hypothesis of
vigilance is driving this uh would
suggest so what are we left with in
terms of what might be driving it so um
if I resort to what we discuss in our
book the laboratory of the self yeah I
believe that
actually I obviously didn't do any
measurements that would
suggest that the sleep was effective but
my own experience with sleep when sleep
is not um when the conditions are not
ideal mhm does suggest that very short
bouts of sleep um interrupted by brief
vigilance over whatever um actually do
have a cumulative input I might expect
that the answer is if you're only
sleeping for a few seconds at a time um
that effectively you're knocked back to
zero whatever the you know and first of
all there's no obvious reason and I'm
sure initially it was not the case that
sleep is necessary to do something
uh some process has to unfold and it can
only happen when you were asleep
initially sleep was bound to be a matter
of dorcy when you were going to be
counterproductive being active but once
you have that period of dormy selection
can build stuff that is best done during
sleep and then require sleep and we know
that human beings uh choire doesn't even
really begin to get to it you can
actually die from lack of sleep right um
and you will die from lack of sleep if
you simply uh remain perpetually awaken
much quicker than you would imagine
there are things processes that need to
be reset uh in the brain and we're not
all fully aware of what they even are um
but from the point of view of there
being necessary processes that require
sleep first of all we've all had the
experience of the 20-minute power nap
right there's one thing to a night's
sleep a full night's sleep that sleep
deprivation if you can't go to sleep for
some reason or you don't manage to sleep
um that you can end up getting to a
place where you're just not really
functional um but that 20 minutes of
sleep can do you a world of good if you
need to get through an hour presentation
right 20 minutes of sleep on no sleep
will actually get you back into a state
where you feel rejuvenated albeit not
for the whole day true although at risk
of pointing out the obvious we're
talking about 4 seconds which is one
300s the amount of time of a 20 minute
right but if I again go laboratory of
the self I don't know how long you know
I've been in the situation where I'm
dozing off briefly and I keep coming
back to wakefulness um and the point is
there is a place where I believe I get
to that you've had 20 minutes and you've
got a temporary burst of you know
cognitive proficiency that's come from
somewhere which I infer to mean that
whatever that process is that works over
20 minutes actually works in small bouts
that add up to something like 20 minutes
and you know I think people will have
had this experience too where
you know I mean the thing that is so
dangerous about driving is that it does
not whereas walking around your body has
a feedback that says don't fall
asleep now right that would be a bad
idea right people do you know
narcoleptics are rare you don't see
people falling asleep walking around
because the proper evolutionary
feedbacks keep you from doing it but
sitting in I saw Professor do it at the
chalkboard
once anybody I know yeah but I'm not
going to say it out here okay all right
um he was old but somebody we like yeah
yeah you didn't know him well okay well
all right so the point is you have the
proper feedbacks when you're walking
around that prevent you from ever
falling asleep you probably live your
whole life and never fall asleep while
walking around driving we've all had the
experience because driving doesn't
produce those feedbacks you're sitting
in a comfortable chair maybe you know
you've got the environment nice and warm
right you're listening to music you like
whatever it is um and the point is no
it's you're hurdling along window 65 M
an hour and this is a bad time to allow
that drowsy feeling to overtake you so
we've all been there but we've also
therefore all I hate to admit it but I
believe it's every driver will have had
this experience where there is no
obvious place to pull off or you're not
that far from home and it's like just
stay awake and you know my grandfather
used to to gum to stay awake that's
actually a pretty good trick but um
window open is also window open is good
but where you know you are like barely
dozing off and you start giving yourself
one eye at a time right then the point
is that yeah one eye terrible terrible
never again will I allow that to happen
but um but the point is there is a point
at which it goes
away where it's not that it just gets
worse and you're dead correct so far
that has not been my experience um but
there's a point at which that little
micro dozing thing actually does cause
something to turn over and so again I
think that it's probably why it's in
strangely in the abstract of that paper
we driving this not
belong um so anyway my laboratory of the
self experiences of uh suboptimal
periods of sleep yeah suggests that this
is not it's not a crazy idea that 4
seconds at a time um would get you
somewhere so here we go that this is so
um I don't believe in Essence but there
are behaviors that are more or less
likely to be affiliated with one sex or
the other and um I did some amount of
longdistance driving when I was young
not very much you did a fair amount we
did some together we would spell each
other um but you did a lot I'm not great
at spelling but in that case I was in
that case you were excellent at it and
um following your footsteps our um
eldest son here has done a lot of
driving and I think had something to say
here it's not very helpful I just find
there are a lot of things you can do
that work sort of you can pull over and
do jumping jacks and caffeine can help
the only thing that really works great
so just like know what you're going to
say you would a staple through your
toe work great hold on you wouldn't have
fallen asleep while you were learning to
drive while you're still at the limit of
your driving ability and so the only
thing that really works is drive at the
limit of your ability speed up like
three times oh God yes for the record
he's
kidding kiding yeah no go with the
staple through the toe much more
recomended you can barely make it around
the corner and stay on the road you stay
fully sorry no um all
right terrible yes what have we done
what have well I don't know but are we
done with penguins yes okay so speaking
of driving okay um as you know um
because you have access to my calendar
and much else um I was in Florida
um I think I would have put together
that even without access to your
calendar really yeah I mean I'm just
saying it at a bare minimum the calendar
rated obvious um I guess yes so anyway I
was sometimes I am pretty sure that I
have better access to your calendar than
you
do I do not doubt that for one second I
don't want it to be that way I'm not
great with calendars or clocks or lots
of other stuff but um but cars
and other things many other things I was
just trying to segue back to you yeah
yeah right um but anyway I was in uh
Florida I was actually back and forth
across Florida um and I ended up in wait
you only went forth or back you didn't
go back and forth you are technically
correct I was I was fourth in Florida um
I don't know who first second and third
were but uh hats off to them spelled
different spelled you would raise that
at this moment has gotten awkward but um
so anyway I was in Florida and uh yep I
uh found myself in Miami with a data
kill mhm and I decided looking at the
map that the Florida keys were in range
for a day trip which is a little
surprising to me that I could get both
directions in a day but it turned out
it's only 3 hours um from where I was
staying in Miami to Key West the
farthest you can go and so I decided to
just do it and I know I I feel a little
bad about this because you've wanted to
get there forever and you just didn't
happen to be on this trip but anyway so
I decided I'm going to go to Key West
I'm going to see Key West and I'm going
to get back see the cats yeah Ste
Hemingway's cats um and as I was driving
through the keys I encountered
indications of something that
somehow though I am a trained
mammologist I did not know existed or if
I did know I've forgotten well enough
that I find no trace of it in my mind
which is the existence of something
called a key deer now he deer is a they
say a subspecies the deer say no no good
catch yes no the mammologist say that
the deer he deer is a subspecies of
white tail deer um white tail deer being
the common East Coast deer um now this
interested me in a number of ways one I
guess I'm not really surprised that
there was a special deer in the keys I
am a little surprised that it still
exists
um because the keys are pretty
welldeveloped deer is pretty delicious
there's hundreds of years of history of
sailors coming through and often times
Sailors have decimated Turtles and
tortoises and the local stuff and I
would have thought that yeah although I
don't know how recent the uh the bridges
are and so Sailors aren't going to tend
to go far inland so you know some some
of those keys are pretty big and sailors
might not you know some keys are pretty
big and some of the habitat is uh
squishy and brambly and so it's possible
that it just wasn't real efficient yeah
um to hunt them in this way so despite
the fact that they were hunted they're
still there yeah um they
are so anyway at the point that I
discovered that they were still there
based on there's one section of the keys
where there's just signs everywhere you
know flashing red lights with a picture
of a deer and mentions of Key Deer and
be careful and all of this you know be
careful dangerous no they get hit a lot
um but anyway I thought wow that's
marvelous I'd love to see this animal
and I you know pulled into some nature
area kinds of places hoping I would
encounter it and I didn't encounter it
and then finally on my way back Sun is
setting um I saw them by the in a little
spot I I hesitate to admit that it was
near the highway but it was near enough
that I could detect that they were there
and I pulled into a church and had a
nice conversation with the folks selling
Christmas trees and then they were they
were cool with me going to chase the
deer and so I did and anyway I wanted to
just show I did get a couple nice photos
and I sent one of them here to Zach Zach
do you want yeah you want to show this
animal so there is a Bea these are quite
tiny he's gorgeous yeah he's a gorgeous
creature um so what what is he like what
is it how tall is he at the shoulder you
think oh he's probably a and a half with
the shoulder yeah it's a very little
animal and this is an adult face looks
adultish it's hard to tell a littleit I
believe it's an adult and uh anyway he
was he was uh and those little chewing
antlers uh they are little antlers I
looked it up both individuals that I saw
had antlers so I thought maybe this was
an exception to the uh M's Only Rule
turns that is not the key deer only the
males have antlers um and only during
ring season and is that what they look
like at the end or is that just new I
think they grow the problem is that what
I read suggests that this was not the
moment on the calendar when they should
have them so I don't know what's going
on my expectation is that those are um
Young new buds but I don't know um and
this guy raised his tail at me that was
about as alarmed as he got yeah
um but anyway he's gorgeous it caused me
to think a number of things one deer are
interesting in that both the white tail
and the mule deer of the
West have this pattern of creating
subspecies that are identifiably
different and I started to wonder about
why that would
be um and my thought was there's
something interesting here where the the
platform the deer platform
is generically useful right there's lots
of habitat hat across both the East and
the West in the center of the country um
that has the basic stuff that you would
want but then there's stuff that might
be modified like the height of uh the
foliage right a tiny deer in the keys
where there's nothing tall growing at
all right there are very few trees there
are some but um everything's pretty low
that a you know a deer that was capable
of maneuvering um would have an
advantage over a deer that was standard
height and you know unable to do uh that
job and so question really which this
raised for me is when does selection
produce a new species when does it
produce a subspecies and what's going on
in that Gap um we have here on the West
Coast we have um mule deer um which gave
rise to a subset Blacktail deer um and
then there's another subset which I'm
forgetting I can't remember what it is
might be Eastern Washington somewhere
but there there's like a triple nested
Set uh amongst the mule
deer um there's also some weird morphs
here on the islands or not on this but
on orcus island oh the pyal yeah uh
piebald deer Yes actually selection
seems to have modified the deer there
suddenly um but anyway I don't have a
ton to say about it except that I
thought it was interesting that there's
this diminutive little white tail deer
in the keys that it still exists yeah um
and it's in many of the keys No at this
point they're connected but I wonder
that's the other interesting thing at
this point the keys are connected it is
limited I think it's um forgive me if
I've got the name wrong is it Pine
something Pine Key um it's it's now
limited to a couple of different Keys
adjacent to one another y but the
historical pattern at least and I think
it's still somewhat evident these deer
are great
swimmers um that is not terribly
surprising most mammals actually do a
better job of swimming than you think
and for these guys bats even bats can
pull it off and things like sloths and
anyway uh being able to swim is actually
near Universal is it is it giraffes that
are the big
exception and they just don't have to
just walk on the bottom and well but I I
think there's like one major exception
and I maybe it's not giraffe
girves but I feel like it's just like
it's too there's too much above the
water and fall over yeah I can't I can't
they only would need to keep their head
above the water yeah but if they're
swimming in the kinds of habitats where
Daves would have to like they have to be
in super deep water and they wouldn't be
able to like get in and swim in shallow
water because yeah I agree it raises
raises questions
um but also there's a question about the
reinforcement you know so in girves um
the there is an there is a structural
issue which is that the head is so far
from the body that messages that need to
get from the head to the body actually
take a long time and so there's certain
things that have to be wired into the
body and you can imagine that the
opportunities for gaves to swim are few
and far between so it may be that the
building of a swimming program into the
body that did not require the head to
participate directly in every motion
never got reinforced and so they can't
so anyway that's at least a plausible
story if if if they are in fact the
exception but um anyway swimming uh the
deer these deer can swim these deer can
swim they have traditionally spread out
farther through the keys they're now
limited to places with intact habitat
but the really cool thing I learned is
that they swim to keys that do not have
uh standing water in the wet season they
need fresh water and so in the wet
season when it falls out of the sky and
collect in various places they will go
to these other keys and then in the dry
season they Retreat to the Keys in which
they have a source of water can you put
the picture back up Zach I was actually
going to ask you it looks like the plant
behind this deer is a bmad no it's not
that okay a palm a but still Palms have
axles as well that collect water they do
um so you're going to have basically
phyto talada you know water collecting
in um living plants uh that are used by
poison frogs but also anyone who wants
to come by and get a drink and doesn't
mind sticking their tongue into a plant
totally yeah y so anyway that's about
the story of it but I was just uh super
excited to run into especially a you
know yes it's a tiny deer but it's a
pretty large mammal um I've never heard
of and that it was uh possible to
encounter it just by being a little
Vigilant that was cool that is that is
awesome all right uh I think I think
we've done it yep I think um we're going
to take take a bit of a break and then
uh come back after 50 minutes or so with
our um special holiday gift episode uh
it won't be that long but it should be
fun and uh Brett's got some unexpected
stuff for for all y'alls um until we see
you next time though we will be back
next week uh same time same place please
consider joining us on locals where
we've got all sorts of great benefits
and um and also go to the store we'll be
talking again more about that uh in the
gift episode dark hor store.org
um check check out my writing at Natural
Selections uh natural selections.
substack
doccom we've got um boy we still we
still have our patreons open and you're
still doing your monthly conversations
in fact you did those from I did one
from the keys was great yeah you drove a
little hot but yeah you did outside in
the keys nice nice nice um and um yeah
so reminder our sponsors this week were
I've forgotten already it was uh Vivo
Barefoot and mind Bloom and uncruise
indeed um all awesome and uh we will
have links to everything we talked about
here in the show notes and just a
reminder that we appreciate you we're
supported by you our audience uh we
appreciate you subscribing to the
brumble channel chamel chamel what's a
chamel is like a cross between a channel
and a camel yeah so I don't know if it's
got one hump or two but do subscribe
and good recovery thank you um like
sharing videos uh we now have um Dave of
our awesome Clips guy putting Clips on
Twitter directly uh so that's where you
can find clips now and we encourage you
to go there and subscribe to the
Darkhorse uh Channel I'll just go with
it on Twitter as
well and get get Clips there and um and
yeah until we see you next time be good
to the ones you love eat good food and
get outside be well
everyone
up